france est aujourd'hui championne du
monde de la mixité dans les conseils
d'administration mais il faut aller plus
loin par jean qatari bonjour 7
coordinatrice du pôle égalité
homme-femme de terra nova ya ce chiffre
qui montre qu'on est champion du monde
45 % 45 % des sièges des conseils
ministration sont désormais occupés par
des femmes on revient de loin on est à
12 % en 2010 est-ce que ça prouve que la
contrainte en l'espèce cette loi copé
zimmermann voter pour le coup en 2010
qui imposait cette montée en puissance
des femmes au sein des conseils et bas à
la loi ça marche en effet ça marche on
observe bien que c'est là où on a mis
des quotas que les choses ont bougé on
l'avait rappelé on est passé de 12 15 %
de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration à 45% des leaders donc
c'est le meilleur on est les meilleurs
on est parti on est parti de bagnes
aujourd'hui effectivement on est les
meilleurs bon sauf que le conseil
administration celle haut de la pyramide
et l'entreprise ce qu'il faut après
c'est descendre d'un cran j'ai envie de
dire et féminisé d'autres instances
dirigeantes en au delà du conseil c'est
pourquoi cette loi la loi reid sein
était votée fin 2021 elle impose je le
rappelle pour les sociétés de plus de
1000 salariés
30% de femmes parmi les cadres
dirigeants d'ici 2027 et 40% d'ici 2030
est ce que cette loi c'est une vraie
question est ce que c'est l'assurance
que plus de femmes auront des postes à
responsabilité dans le futur je pense
qu'on a de bonnes raisons d'être
optimiste ça a marché dans les conseils
d'administration mais là où la loire x1
est intéressante c'est parce que on
pensait en féminisant les conseils
d'administration qu'automatiquement on a
les féminiser l'échelon du dessus le
seul héritier voilà que sally ruisseler
c'est le terme qu'on utilise son
temps ça n'a pas été le cas au niveau
des comités exécutifs ou deco dire donc
ses directeurs directrice marketing
communication stratégie etc on n'a pas
eu ce décollage donc effectivement
imposé encore une fois ce qu'on appelle
des quotas donc 30 ou 40% de femmes dans
ses instances il ya de bonnes raisons
pour que ça pour que ça fasse bouger les
choses donc pour vous à vous écouter
cette loi est une avancée qui est
majeure même si j'en veux dire elle ne
s'applique pas aux pme et là on se dit
qu'effectivement la mixité de la mixité
dans les pme on est un sujet 1 oui c'est
vrai alors déjà évidemment les pme les
tpe ne sont pas soumises à cette
obligation parce que de par leur taille
elles m'ont n'y a parfois pas de conseil
d'administration pas de comité exécutif
donc évidemment on a on a moins la
possibilité de surveiller ou d'imposer
ou de contraindre ses frusques auraient
plus de difficultés à s'organiser mais
on pourrait imaginer par exemple
d'encourager plutôt les pme qui aurait
autant de femmes que d'hommes dans leurs
dirigeants par différentes mesures ça
pourrait être
en accès privilégié à certains marchés
publics par exemple ou alors conditionné
voilà c'est ce qu'on entend aussi
souvent en ce moment
l'écoconditionnalité on pourrait penser
à de l'écho et gars conditionnalité
pourquoi pas pour pour être dans une
logique plutôt de valorisation de ces
entreprises plus petites qui feraient le
boulot et pour les boîtes qui font pas
le boulot qui ne respectent pas cette
loi fixe un ce que est ce qu'il ya des
amants de ce qu'elles sont vraiment
dissuasive oui c'est 1% de la masse
salariale va quand même
l'expédition après quand on quand on
veut recruter en interne
promouvoir des femmes est ce qu'on les
trouve vraiment je pose la question
parce que le patronat le medef mais pas
trop non sens large parfois on entend
souvent que certains profils sont rares
sur le marché profils féminins et les
secteurs où la question se posera
peut-être le btp mais sinon voilà est-ce
que c'est un argument c'est une réalité
ou est ce que c'est un peu spécieux
comme argument ça quand on cherche on
trouve non c'est vrai qu'on a de la
difficulté à trouver des femmes dans
certains secteurs d'activité mais aussi
à certains postes parce que on le sait
femmes et hommes n'exerce pas au même
niveau hiérarchique ni aux mêmes métiers
ni dans les mêmes secteurs d'activité
donc effectivement on a de la difficulté
quand on regarde un peu la composition
de ses comités de direction on sait
qu'on a beaucoup plus d'hommes qui vont
être dans des fonctions
communication des ressources humaines
aux femmes le marketing aux femmes c'est
schématique c'est vraiment pour le coup
c'est pas caricatural ya une part de
vérité on en est encore là aujourd'hui
mais les postes pour les hommes et puis
des postes pour les femmes alors je
dirais pas que ce sont des postes pour
les hommes ou pour les femmes mais pour
le comprendre il faut regarder ce qui se
passe un petit peu en amont du marché du
travail aujourd'hui il ya peu de métiers
qui sont mixtes et on a encore des
filières d'études dans lesquels on a
beaucoup de femmes dans les filières du
soin de l'éducation de la beauté et du
bien-être on va avoir beaucoup de femmes
alors que dans les filières du btp de
l'industrie chez les ingénieurs on va
encore avoir beaucoup d'hommes on est
quand même souvent dans un prisme qui
consiste à vouloir attirer les femmes
vers des métiers masculins mais en fait
assez peu l' inverse on se dit peu
essayons d'attirer des hommes dans les
métiers par exemple du soin qui sont des
métiers d'avenir les métiers de la santé
sont des métiers d'avenir est en réalité
on retrouve aussi cette répartition très
genre et donc différencier selon le sexe
mais il faudrait inciter les deux à
ouvrir leur champ des possibles les
hommes comme m mais sur la tête encore
une fois ça vient d'où le fait qu'ils
petit peu de femmes qui soient embauchés
dans ces métiers là on retrouve la
maison on préfère laver des métiers
prometteur d'avenir pour lesquels il ya
même de la pénurie oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai et ça on l'expliqué très bien on
sait que de manière assez précoce dans
leur choix d'orientation
on va voir comment ça commence à l'école
évidemment au moment où on est on à 13
14 ans on est un ado on s'oriente il ya
quelque chose de très fort qui fait que
l'on a besoin de s'identifier à un
groupe de pairs on a besoin de prouver
qu'on est une vraie fille un vrai garçon
et ça passe aussi par adopter ce qu'on
suppose être les compétences les
préférences supposée des filles et des
garçons et ça c'est très fort il faut
pas le sous-estimer en tout cas cette
loi rixin va dans le bon sens c'est une
avancée voilà merci beaucoup kenza tahri
coordinatrice du pôle égalité
homme-femme de terra nova merci
[Musique]